I love that check out kim kardashian and  chrissy teigen flashing a whole lot of  cleavage on tuesday night in Los Angeles  the ladies hit up a GQ bash celebrating  the 10th annual love sex and madness  issue Kim is the cover girl and she  looked fierce in a skin tight black  dress that was my mood Chrissy opted for  a low-cut knee-length white dress but  check out these snaps from her car ride  the new moms cleavage was totally  optimized due to a case of the hiccups  every day is so different both Kim and  Chrissy stepped out on Monday night as  well to celebrate Khloe's 32nd birthday  bud opes Kim had a slight wardrobe  malfunction when photogs snapped her  leaving look close her butt pad peeks  through her skin tight black skirt it  was really tough for me